[Music]
this is a map of known sediment basins
in the United States many of these
regions hold deposits of natural gas and
crude oil now this map compares how much
crude oil each basin Hoult's of the many
formations scattered across the country
one reigned supreme
with our new estimates of the Permian
Basin that that resource estimate is on
par with what has been estimated in the
Middle East the first oil well was
drilled in the Permian Basin of Texas
and New Mexico roughly a century ago and
now the basin produces more than four
million barrels of crude oil on a daily
basis
surging Permian production has helped
make the u.s. the top oil producer in
the world that growth hasn't come
without challenges let's unravel how
this trip of desert propelled America's
ascent to crude oil superpower the
Permian Basin first commercial
operations began at Mitchell County and
Big Lake Texas the region's resources
soon proved critical data collected in
the 20th century show wells in the
Permian yielding 10 to 22 percent of
national crude oil production that oil
was key in moments of international
conflict crude was a key commodity in
world war ii refined fuels stemming from
the gulf coast powered engines and aided
in the manufacture of everything from
roads to uniforms and bombs and during
the global oil crisis of 1973 oil from
the Permian helped stabilize US markets
as OPEC nations cut supply in an embargo
for years there is steady growth in the
region but following the 1970s energy
crisis oil prices dropped in drilling
became far less profitable production
dwindled meanwhile new extraction
methods developed incrementally
hydraulic fracturing also known as
fracking was invented in the late 1940s
but decades would pass before it was
used widely in the modern version of
this process producers drill through
several layers of the Earth's crust then
they blast a mixture of water sand and
chemicals through the rock at a high
pressure this fractures the rock and
unlocks oil from the crust for many
years producers used fracking to
maximize production from conventional
resources large reservoirs of crude oil
that were easy to draw to the surface
but a breakthrough in the nearby Barnett
Shale unlocked vast new reserves in
shale rock formations in 1998 an
engineer and Mitchell energy used a
dramatically higher ratio of water to
chemicals and sand to blast through
sediment the new method made it possible
to extract resources that weren't
previously commercially viable while
fracking helped producers recover every
drop possible new drilling technologies
expanded their reach
especially horizontal drilling it became
common in the Permian in the 2000s the
advent of horizontal drilling meant that
producers could target multiple
formations from a single site at the
surface these wells can sometimes
stretch for miles fracking and
horizontal drilling are particularly
effective for the basins geology
the Herman's Western sub-basin the
Delaware has more depth than other parts
according to the USGS because it they
are so thick industry is able to put in
multiple Wells within that stack of
units and drill multiple horizons to
produce oil and that is really what's
unique about that area the Permian has
significant deposits of shale rock and
the combination of fracking and
horizontal drilling in the 2000s made
the tight oil and shale recoverable this
combination set the stage for the shale
revolution which picked up steam in the
2010s this put the basin at the center
of a crude oil Renaissance in America
the national production rate which had
dwindled for decades mounted a
turnaround since the mid aughts the
national crude production rate has
mostly climbed upward on the strength of
the Permian say for a short decline that
began in 2015 the year prior US crude
prices plunged 50 percent many producers
in the basin scaled back production to
prevent further losses but the producers
that survived were in position to drive
the Permian to new heights moving ahead
to 2018 the united states surpassed
Saudi Arabia and Russia to become the
world's leading oil producer but this
production brought new challenges
first is the issue of well placement
here's an oil field outside of Odessa
Texas in 2003 by 2018 these fields were
brimming with well pads that can put a
damper on production rates producers in
recent years have tried to space wells
more closely together to maximize the
amount of oil and gas that they're able
to get at their acreage they found in
some instances that that hurts
the output of individual wells producers
are kind of going back and increasing
the distance between the wells that they
drill the result is that they have fewer
overall locations to drill on the
acreage that they have and the problems
don't end there
the pipelines that run through the
Permian had a capacity issue in recent
years oil production in the Permian has
increased faster than pipeline capacity
leading to bottlenecks and discounted
prices and when capacity isn't
sufficient producers are instead left to
transport resources by rail or truck or
they have to slow down production new
pipelines are scheduled to come online
in late 2009 teen which could help
alleviate price discounts but the energy
producers in the Permian can't escape
their fraud connection to the climate
and environment consider the issue of
flaring the natural gas flowing from the
Permian is mostly a byproduct when
producers drill for oil
they also unearthed natural gas which is
less profitable facing limited
profitability and pipeline capacity
issues many drillers choose to burn
their fuel on-site flaring in the
Permian is at all-time highs according
to rystad energy that's a concern first
of all because it's a colossal waste of
energy
but more so they can cause local air
quality issues that they're not burning
properly and we're releasing a bunch of
greenhouse gas into the air as carbon
dioxide that we're wasting so flaring
benefits nobody the only thing that it's
better than is releasing the methane
into the air directly the string of boom
towns and man camps along the Permian
Basin represent the heartbeat of
American energy
all eyes are on the region as the u.s.
fights to maintain its position atop
global oil markets